[Anna]: We live in a world where it's become not only normal to share incredibly personal information...
But encouraged, whether that's a vague tweet...
[Congress]: I never get treats anymore... I'm not sure if it's a human who takes care of me OR A BITCH!
[Anna]: Hey! You little f---.
Or a very specific detailed post on Facebook.
[Congress]: I lifted up my leg and lift my penis today for 45 minutes... It was the only treat I got.
[Anna]: Ew...
And I started wondering: is all of this oversharing bad?
I have always been on the side of optimistic about technology
and really loving the potential of the Internet,
but I understand that not everybody sees it like I do.
*Flashes 2nd Anna*
[2nd Anna]: Oh my gah.
[Anna]: I mean obviously I'm not one to talk. I share...
horribly personal information to hundreds of thousands of strangers on the Internet.
And I like to think that I'm helping
and I'm putting myself out there
and I'm somehow reaching human beings
through this cold-impersonal-digital-landscape.
But, you know, maybe people are actually watching because I'm such a shit-show you can't turn away.
*Flashes 2nd Anna*
[2nd Anna]: *Screams in horror*
[Anna]: This is a topic that I've thought a lot about.
And I knew my oversharing was...
really unhealthy when a few years ago my brother
and I walked into my house, to find that this small bird had been ripped apart by my cats.
[3rd Anna]: ...oh my god, that was crazy right? *laughs*
*le gasp* *le screams*
[Anna]: It's horrible right? Like the thirst for attention is real.
And so now I know if you're frantically trying to capture a moment before you can genuinely react to it.
It's probably a bad sign.
[4th Anna]: *frantic* Oh my god, omg, omg, omg... Wait please. Can we at least take a selfie before I die.
[Killer]: Oh yeah, of course.
[4th Anna]: Oh okay, good. You ready?
(1, 2, 3 *picture snap*) x3.
Are you happy with that one?
[Killer]: Oh, ... can I? *does hair*
[4th Anna]: Oh yeah, for sure for sure.
[Killer]: Look good?
[4th Anna]: Mmh. There you go.
[4th Anna]: Wait, do you have like a prop? Like were you gonna stab me or something?
[Killer]: I was gonna... *choking motion*
[4th Anna]: Choke? Can you do that? I'll look scary. Ready?
(And *picture snap*) x3
[4th Anna]: R. I. P. me.
Cool, I'm ready to die now. *chokes*
[Anna]: And so now I try to manage myself by asking: why exactly am I sharing this?
Am I hoping to spread the word about a good cause?
Do I want to inspire or help someone?
Or do I just want to make someone hella jelly?
[5th Anna]: *picture snap* x3
[5th Anna]: *typing* Look and how good of a mom I am...
[Anna]: With sharing, I've oscillate a lot between...
loving the potential and hating the reality.
Because even when it seems like someone is sharing something genuine, when it's online,
it can't be a hundred percent genuine, because we all know how we come across when we post things,
there's always gonna be a part of you that purposely paints yourself in the best light. And I am no exception,
I mean I know the more honest I am,
usually the better the message in the video,
so even my honesty is ultimately motivated by how sharing with others is going to benefit me.
But I do believe in the power of oversharing, I do,
I think it's because of the vast
overpopulated nature of the internet that you can learn about anything that literally piques your interest.
Like I can find out how many other people have these gross red bumps on their legs
from hiking in Machu Picchu or
if I want to know what it's like to get a colonoscopy: I can read dozens of accounts or even pegging, if I'm like what
is pegging like for those people? I can read about all the different couples and what they think about this topic.
TMI, there's just no such thing anymore.
The Internet is ultimately a tool
and how you choose to utilize that tool is completely up to you. Whether you're addicted or isolated from it,
whether it's a great source of knowledge or an awful place with misogyny. In any extreme or
moderation, the knowledge is out there.
It's kind of up to you how much you want to contribute.
I'm Anna Akana, stay right here for an animated sponsored message from Miss Bethany Radloff.
And I also want to say thank you to Meghan McCarthy for doing the voice of Congress.
Your voice is so adorable and great.
Please check out her channel.
She's an amazing voice-over artist and actress and all the things.
And stay right here to hear her talk some more.
[Meghan McCarthy]: Hey guys! It's Meghan McCarthy.
You should click on my face here to watch some of my videos.
Go on, do it, touch my face.
It's okay.
[Congress]: *burps*
Thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring today's video.
Squarespace has an array of award-winning templates, blah blah blah.
Do I really have to do this mom? *groan*
They have an all-in-one platform,
which means no installs, patches, or upgrades ever.
WHO CARES ABOUT THIS MOM?
24-hour customer service, simple domain setup experience, any kind of website...
You've been doing these ads for two years, people already know this.
Do I really have to tell them to go to squarespace.com
to start their free trial and use the offer code "ANNA" for 10% off at checkout? *sigh*
*sigh* Fine. Whatever.
Squarespace.